All right.
Ariel Tseitlin, good morning.
Good morning.
How are you doing?
I'm doing well. How are you today?
Good. It's an interesting time.
I feel like everybody's almost adjusted
to this new normal, right?
Yeah. I mean, I don't know,
if you want to call it normal,
but it certainly is a new way
of experiencing life.
Definitely. I mean after, what it's been,
like twelve weeks already,
waking up and just opening the computer
and getting ready for the first meeting.
Not even thinking about
which office I have to go to.
I mean, that's unfortunately for me,
already becoming a new norm.
But we can only be helpful.
Ariel, such an impressive background.
And I can't wait to talk to you
about scaling and about cyber security.
And your different experiences
from an MBA at Wharton
to being an executive within Netflix,
and really overseeing
some incredible incredible scale,
and different challenges there
that I'd love to hear about.
And now, going to be a partner
at Scale Venture Partners.
And sitting on the boards
of some incredible companies
like Honeycomb and PerimeterX,
whom I admire.
Ariel, who are you?
Give me a little bit of a rundown,
and then I have some some deep dives
that I want to do with you.
Sure. So first, I'll give you
the geographical history.
So, originally from Georgia
in the former Soviet Union,
the country, not the state,
which is something I would like
to preface or [--] with.
Moved at a young age to Israel.
Spent about seven years there
growing up as a kid.
And then, my dad got a job here
in the Bay Area and moved here,
about the end of middle school.
And lived in the Bay Area ever since.
From a career standpoint,
I really followed my father's footsteps.
He was a software engineer back when
they weren't called software engineers.
And he just really taught me
the ins and outs of programming.
And I enjoyed that
from just a very young age.
When did you start programming?
Say again?
I started programming back in Israel.
Gosh, I think I was,
so, I left Israel when I was 10.
And this was a couple of years
before I left.
So, probably, seven or eight.
My mom signed me up for some
basic programming class for teenagers.
But she had some a connection there.
They were able to get me on early
because I was just very interested in it.
I mean, today with Code Monkey
and all these different softwares,
if you're seven and eight
and you're not coding yet,
you're a little bit out of the game.
But in your time,
so, going to programming
at seven or eight,
that's pretty unheard of.
Yeah, it was fine.
I got my first Commodore 64,
which was the first computer
I played around with
and had just incredible
amount of fun with it.
So, when I came to the states
I knew what my career path was
without thinking about it too much.
So, I went and got computer science degree
from UC Berkeley.
And started out as a software engineer.
Had an incredible fulfilling time
doing it for a number of years.
And then, got a little a little bored
with just the coding side of it.
And I was at Siebel Systems at the time.
And the company
was just growing like crazy.
This was back in the late '90s.
And I got the opportunity
to manage a team.
So, I said, "Hey, why not?"
"This looks interesting."
And the different challenge
that I don't understand anything about.
So, what could possibly go wrong?
And so, I started managing a team
and really went into
engineering management from there.
What was it like doing that transition
from an engineer to managing
a team of engineers?
I made that transition early in the IDF
and it was a little bit different
from what I expected it to be.
Yeah. I really enjoyed it.
Particularly back then,
as a first time manager,
I think, these days too,
of the first my manager, I mean,
you're really going to bridging the gap
between being one of the experts,
from the expert from the technical side,
which is, what got you successful
and got you the opportunity
to become a manager.
To learning how to handle the human side
of it and the interpersonal side of it,
and the team and dynamics of it.
And so, this is I think, a common thread
that goes through my selection process
when I think about opportunities.
And both on the job side
as well as project side is.
If I don't feel like I am learning
more than I am teaching,
then I just get a little bit bored
in a particular role that I'm in.
So, for that, it was like,
this is a whole new world.
I don't understand very much about it.
It sounds really interesting.
And so, I went, I took Siebel at the time,
had a bunch of internal classes
that I took around situational leadership.
And you know, the usual slate, right?
And I did try to get up to speed
on being a first line manager.
And I loved all that.
And so, it was a very different
set of muscles that you have to build.
You have to know how to talk
and understand people rather than code,
which is very different.
Code is much more predictable,
I would say.
But I enjoyed it.
And so, that got me started
down that path.
And then, I got promoted fairly quickly
into different bigger and bigger teams.
And then, Siebel got acquired by Oracle
back in, it was in 2006.
And so, that was a time for me
to say, "Pause."
And say, "Okay, what's next?"
Oracle. I don't want to disparage
the company in any way.
But it was never on my list of,
hey, this is the company
that I wanted to go work for.
It was a relatively large organization.
And that wasn't
what really appealed to me.
I really like the small team, and at the
startup entrepreneurial side of things.
So, I decided to stay at Oracle
post the acquisition, but go back
and fulfill an earlier part of my desire
in my career,
which was get a better understanding
of the other side of the business.
I went I did my computer science
undergrad at Cal.
I also, my plan was to do
a double major in business.
And as many plans, that one's didn't come
into complete fruition.
So, you settled for an MBA at Wharton?
Say again?
Yes, that's right. That's right.
So, I decided to do the MBA work.
It was actually a funny story
because I made the decision,
it was one of those things that,
you think about it for years,
but then you make the decision on a dime.
And so,  I made a decision,
I think, within like a couple of weeks
of the application due date.
I remember my family and I
were going to Tahoe over the holiday break
in December. And that was when
the applications were due.
And so, I was busy writing
my entrance essay
for why they should take me,
as my friends and family
were skiing on the slopes.
But anyway,
Wharton was a great experience.
Particularly coming from such
a heavy tech background,
I had a really hard time understanding
what the other side of the business did.
I was, looked at like sales and marketing
as overhead.
So, what are those guys doing?
We're doing all the hard stuff.
We're building everything.
They're out there trying to have drinks
and dinner with customers.
And living life
while we're paying their bills,
while we're also
working hard building, right?
We meet in the engineers of the company.
So, I figure, there's something there
that I wanted
to understand better ourselves.
So, Wharton gave me, I think,
a great perspective on that.
It was a really rewarding experience.
I would do it again in a heartbeat
if I had the chance.
Part of the appeal to me was,
again, I just loved learning so much.
That this was just
an intensive period of learning.
Where I was spending
20 hours a week, probably,
while working at Oracle
and doing classes and meetings
and all that.
And I just had a tremendous amount of fun.
I love that.
Ariel, when did you get excited
about scaling?
The word scale.
Well, I mean, it was almost,
it's funny you say that.
Because it was never really
something I pursued.
It was something in the background
that had to be done, right?
It's almost like good design.
It's not really something you,
at least for me, it wasn't something
I got passionate about.
But, as I went through
these different experiences,
it was something that I started developing,
more and more experience.
And whether it's starting
from smaller companies and building them
into larger teams and companies,
or it was the technical side of scaling
and starting out with a handful of users
that are mostly are friends and family
and going to thousands
and millions of users.
That was almost something
that had to be done.
That you think about your success
and pre-plan for your success early on,
rather than a path that I followed.
So, Netflix I think Netflix was the time
when that understanding of scaling
and how to build scalable
and distributed systems
really emerged for me.
[--]
Yeah.
You're the director
of Cloud Solutions at Netflix.
One of the most heavy consumers
of any cloud infrastructure
you can imagine.
I mean, that must be a crazy experience
in terms of scale,
in terms of responsibility. To understand
how to operate at scale, right?
I mean, this is unprecedented scale.
Yeah. I mean, in Netflix, I had the luxury
of actually working at a place like Netflix.
And Netflix, and I got to tell you,
if you don't already know,
just an incredible company.
The management culture there, and just
the kind of people that the company
is able to attract is just incredible.
I've never been in any other organization
where I felt the team was,
well, I take that back,
there were maybe one other time
when we had a group of 10 people
that were the most the highest,
best tech people in the company
who put together for a small project.
But outside of that, in any kind of scale,
a thousand engineers, I think,
was roughly the size of the organization
when I was there on Netflix and working.
Everyone you go to is just,
knows what they're doing. Expert.
And not just that, but also,
like a mature individual.
Not somebody that has to be a manager.
We read for one of my classes at Stanford,
we read there,
seven of your 100 page slide.
The Culture Deck. Yeah.
The Culture Deck. Unbelievable.
I mean, that was just incredible to see.
Yeah. I mean, I'll tell you a funny one
if you want stories.
I'll tell you a funny story.
Before Netflix, I was at a company
called Sungevity,
which was also pretty cool company.
They were doing residential solar.
And my team was responsible
for technology, which was
the first time in the industry
that allowed homeowners
to get a solar system design
for their roofs,
without ever having the contractor
come after their homes
and measured it, right?
So, we use aerial satellite imagery
in order to create
three dimensional models and design.
And then have a remote solar to design it,
but, it's less relevant.
I was on the management team there.
I was running the technology part
of the business. And the last
executive management team meeting
that I was in the company,
was all of us sitting down
and reviewing the Netflix culture slides
as a management team, and saying,
"This is a great set of cultures slides."
"As inpirationally, what can we pick
from these things
to incorporate into our organization?"
Amazing.
And then, a month or two later,
I think, I was at the company of Netflix.
So, that was serendipitous.
And funny enough,
it wasn't even planned.
So, I didn't actually go and apply there.
I connected to somebody
at a social gathering
who was working there
and he got me introduced.
So, Netflix, the picture of scaling there
was just incredible. And I'd say,
not just from the technical side,
also, organizationally.
Like the way that they were able to scale
this freedom
and responsibility culture there,
which I still, to this day quote and love,
is one that I just,
I haven't seen effective anywhere else.
And that just empowers individuals
to do just amazing things.
Wow. That's incredible.
So, I want to move on
to Scale Venture Partners.
Because I think, the work
that you're doing there
is really incredible.
And your expertise side on the industries
you're focused on.
And I'd love you to tell me
a little bit more, what does it mean.
What is Scale Venture Partners?
And what is it about
cloud infrastructure, cyber security,
the companies you invest in?
And why are you so excited about that?
Because you're also coming
from a very management background.
And not too many people who go
also the management route have that passion
for cybersecurity and infrastructure.
Yet you seem to have that interesting
junction of the both of them.
Yeah.
As with most things, some was by design.
And in some, was just the path
that ended up being taken.
So, first, I'll give you
a blurb about scale.
Scale, it's been around
for a few decades now.
I joined, thankfully, a team
that was fully formed
and extremely successful.
So, that was a wonderful
organization to join.
That it was already successful
and doing great things.
So, I joined in 2013.
And I was doing fund for the firm.
And we're now currently on fund six,
and will at some point
be raising fund seven.
The mission of the firm
is really to help companies
once they build a product
and have some initial market validation
to take those early revenues.
And scale and build it
into the business, right?
So, the term "scale", that refers to
scaling organizations, scaling revenues,
scaling businesses.
So, what we don't invest in is
typically the seed stage. When it's,
the folks coming out of university
and they have an idea,
or out of industry and they have an idea
and they want the capital
in order to build that.
That's the part of the market
that we don't address
from a capital standpoint.
But once they expand,
they're six, 12, 18 months, whatever.
Building it,
getting some initial design partners,
getting some market validation
and some early revenues,
that's where we get involved.
Typically series As, series Bs, series Cs.
Different stages in that scaling phase
and help them build those revenues.
And a lot of what the firm's resources
are oriented around, is, how do you avoid
some of the common scaling mistakes.
When do you hire.
When's the right time to hire.
And what are some of these
biggest mistakes in business?
I was just gonna say, most often the time,
the answer is,
when you think it's the time to hire,
it means probably it's too late.
You should've started six months ago
or 12 months ago.
I've been hearing that so much.
Yeah. When do you start building
some of these processes in place
around understanding conversion,
around understanding
your pipeline generation.
All of this go to market side
of the business,
which is usually the set up systems
that you have to build
after you've got the product
and you've been successful
getting your product to market.
So, that's the idea of scale.
And we've had the, I guess,
the, I'd say part luck.
Part, our own picking,
selected some great companies
to be part of the portfolio,
and some great successes in the past.
Something I'm particularly proud of,
in terms of my own.
When you do join a company,
and you join their journey
as they're about to scale, so,
let's say they're raising their series A,
they have some paying customers,
they have had a market validation,
and they're ready to scale their product
and to grow it,
What role do you take
in helping them do that?
Are you more of, sort of a bystander
who is just over looking and giving them
a Yea or Nay?
Are you very active
in looking at their plan
and talking to their customers,
and understanding whether
they actually have market validation
or, if they're just
under the false assumption?
Where do you fit in there?
Yeah, we talked to a lot of customers
before we make the investment.
So, that's typically
part of our diligence process
is to understand,
Is there really a fit there.
Is their product market fit there.
And so, we do, we'll talk to
a couple dozen different customers.
Both customers, as well as prospects,
as well as folks in our own network
who would be typical buyers
and to validate that there's
a product market fit there.
So, that typically happens
before we make the investment.
And so, we get
to that level of conviction.
And by the way, is that easier
as you're more concentrated
on a specific industry?
So, if you're concentrated on
cloud infrastructure and cybersecurity,
Yeah. Absolutely.
Because it's all the same players
come up quite often, right?
Well, that's one.
And then the other is,
you just have a much better ability
to determine the quality
of the answers you're getting, right?
So, you can put people in the bucket
of these folks understand it,
because they understand
the complexities of the world.
And when it comes to infrastructure,
and it might be early adopters,
and early signals,
or these folks are just going to do
what they read about
in the technical press.
And then, that gives you
a different type of data point.
So, I certainly think
having that experience,
I think let's you understand
where the market is going,
maybe a few months, a few quarters earlier
than when it would be otherwise obvious.
So, back to your question around
how involved do we get,
I mean, the answer is, fairly involved.
And this is something that
I personally find extremely satisfying
and rewarding about this role is,
I don't want to be there sitting
once a quarter, or saying:
Yea or Nay,
Do this. Don't do this.
Because I don't think that's effective.
In the areas where I feel I can add value,
I get fairly involved in those.
Those fall into
a couple of different buckets,
One is, well,
what's the expertise of the firm.
That's certainly something
that we have a lot of resources
and personal experience with.
And that's around,
how do you scale revenues,
and how do you build
some of these systems I mentioned.
And then the other side is around
just the product
and the technical side of it.
And that's something that I think,
I bring uniquely from my own background.
In understanding how to build
engineering teams,
understanding how to build products
and even some of the technical
and scaling side of it.
One of the first things I did
when I started scale,
before I could really add any value
on the venture side,
because I was completely new to venture
when I first joined, is,
I went round to different
portfolio companies
and essentially gave them my talk
that I used to give it Netflix, around,
Hey, how do you build large,
scalable, distributed systems
that are fault tolerant and resilient?
And that was something
that was very valuable
to those engineering teams.
But also because you got to experience
the portfolio companies potentially
at a deeper way
than a lot of other partners did.
Because from understanding also,
not every partner is involved
with every company.
And you got to understand
the portfolio a little bit better.
Ariel, the last minute that we have,
are there specific places
that the market is going to
that you're especially excited about that?
That young people coming out
of 8200 or Stanford could be thinking up
in the realms of cloud infrastructure,
cyber security.
The world has changed dramatically
over the past few months.
What are some of the the key places
that you think bright minds
should put their effort?
You know, that's a really good question.
And I can give you an answer
to that question.
But my first reaction to that would be,
don't listen to anything
that a venture capitalist
or investor tells you.
It should be the area
that you're focusing on.
Because honestly, even I come from
a fairly technical background,
but it's now seven years
since I've been an operator.
And my information is,
it's gotten fairly fast, okay, right?
And so, whatever I think it is,
it's probably things
that I've heard from others.
And, what I would encourage folks to do
is understand,
from their own vantage point
where are gaps in the market
and then build to that.
Because, it's those folks
that are in the trenches,
that are building it,
that are understanding
where those challenges lie.
That I think, is the best position.
We figure it out later
after it's been built,
and after the customers already tell us
that this is something.
So, my initial answer,
in terms of specific areas,
I think the cloud infrastructure
side of things is just
extremely nascent at this point.
We're in the very very early days
of having, we've just released DMs, right?
As a technology, when it comes to
fast forward to the equivalent
and the infrastructure.
So, every company that's doing anything
at a reasonable scale
from an engineering standpoint,
needs to build its own platform
from the ground up.
And usually constructed
in different pieces.
So, I'm still waiting to see
who will solve this problem,
who is going to come up with a way
of building cloud native applications
where you don't have to custom built
to AWS and GCP and USHER,
and you don't have to worry
about scaling up.
You see two instances.
You don't have to worry about setting up
security groups and ELBs and so on.
So, like that piece of it,
I think is still missing.
So, that's one that I'm always
on the lookout for
on the infrastructure side.
The other side of it,
I think there's also around various parts
in the development lifecycle.
I hear that a lot. Yeah.
Yeah. As the infrastructure changes,
the management and orchestration
and workflow piece of it
has to change as well.
So, whether it's in software or quality
or in deployment,
each one of those pieces is,
every time there's a shift
in the underlying infrastructure,
the management side of it has to solve.
As a software engineer myself,
going through these processes
and working on a variety of projects,
both professionally, academically,
I definitely see that as a huge potential
and a place that I'm personally
very excited about.
Ariel, before we leave,
I have to ask you the hardest question
putting you on the spot one last time,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself,
or that any of your partners
at Scale Venture Partners,
would describe you as.
I don't want to answer that question.
I hate talking about myself.
And certainly is not something I enjoy.
That's definitely, I think,
a valuable answer.
Maybe, I say Curious.
I'll take curious.
Curious is good enough for all three.
And I appreciate the response.
And I think, that's also something
that is, I think, quite interesting
with people who are really excited
about helping others accomplish things
and watching a lot of great people
around them succeed.
And I truly truly appreciate it.
Ariel, thank you for your time.
Toda raba.
Absolutely. I mean,
I'll leave your listeners
with one last talk, which is,
I think everybody
who is your peer right now
has an incredible place in life
that you don't get to experience
very often. You're the world.
The world is the opportunity right now.
And so, don't listen to everybody
that says, "No.",
for every one of your ideas.
Because you're gonna get 100 Nos
for Every every you Yes you get.
So, have the passion.
Have the conviction to do
what you believe in.
And I think you'll have
an incredible time in your life.
100%.
Ariel, toda raba.
Thank you very much.
Thanks. Great time. Bye bye.